This could be my last chance
You're up to something, what is it?
It's not exactly legal.
I want to see you get hurt more than you
already have.
This would be a cure.
I went from dying.
To feeling more alive than ever.
Increased strength and speed.
The ability is echolocation.
And the overpowering urge to consume blood
How far are we allowed to go?
To fix something that's broken.
Until the remedy is worse than the disease.
Michael Morbius.
Got tired of doing the whole good guy thing, huh?
What's up what's up doc?
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Morbius trailer video
Sony just made a big announcement about
the release date there's a bunch of
spider-man and venom 2 Easter eggs going
on in this too there will be some
moments of crossover so I'll explain how
that's going to work I'll also be doing
a venom 2 trailer video soon so
definitely hit subscribe if you haven't
already to be one of the first to see
that when it comes out it's supposed to
come out next month and I think that's
probably going to be accurate even
though all the delays have been pushing
everything press F in the chat to pay
your respects to the New Mutants movie
so we'll talk about the Marvel
spider-man venom 2 connections first and
what's going on with Matt Smith's
character Jared Harris's character and
then I'll talk about what's going on
with the Morbius release date in the
venom tube release date thankfully they
finished filming venom 2 before the big
virus outbreak but the way they're
treating the Morbius spider-man
crossover moments is way simpler than
you ever expected it's not some
complicated multiverse explainer it's
not Tobey Maguire spider-man even though
Sam Raimi himself is directing Doctor
Strange to multiverse of madness and I
know a lot of you guys that are big
Toby's spider-man fans want to see some
Easter eggs for his version during that
but what's going on during the Morbius
movie is all about Tom Hollands
spider-man it has a lot of you probably
suspected when that spider-man suit
shows up in its Tobey Maguire spider-man
suit but it's referencing Tom Hollands
spider-man and totally doesn't make
sense there's a really funny reason for
that too so quick timeline clarification
on when the Morbius movie actually takes
place it takes place after the events of
spider-man far from homes post-credit
scene with Mysterio's video and jejune
de Jameson putting spider-man on blast
to the world that's why it says murderer
in graffiti across the spider-man suit
the reason why it's Tobey Maguire's
spider-man suit is because when they
released this trailer they needed to get
something together so quickly without
completely giving away the fact that Tom
Hallows spider-man is going to
eventually be crossing over into these
movies maybe they just hope that fans
would forget about the fact that Kevin
Feige said the spider-man was already
going to crossover with the venom
characters and they just wouldn't think
about it when they saw the spider-man
suit or maybe they failed to assume that
fans would notice that it's not the
right
spider-man suit so just to be clear
Tobey Maguire is not crossing over into
the Morbius movie it's intended to be a
reference to Tom Holland's spider-man and
they're just going to change the suit to
his spider-man suit before the movies
released there's also a lot of sinister
six stuff going on during the movie
through Michael Keaton's vulture
character and also finally introducing
the idea of Oscorp into the sonne venom
verse you can think of it as the
spider-man universe but you have to be
really careful with the way you talk
about how these movies connect to the
Marvel spider-man movies so venom
himself is not part of the MCU for
instance Morbius is not part of the MCU
but technically when all the Tom Holland
spider-man Easter eggs show up in
the more via smoothie they're just going to
treat it like Morbius and venom do exist
on the same earth as Tom Hollands
spider-man it's not the multiverse it's
just that in the Morbius movie when
they're referencing spider-man's stuff
like Michael Keaton's vulture from
spider-man homecoming they're not going to
be referencing to many of the other
Avengers and I don't think that Sony is
allowed to actually include the other
Avengers on screen but I think they're
allowed to reference the snap from
Avengers infinity war in the blip from
Avengers endgame remember that funny
interview with Kevin Feige where he got
turned into a meme because of his
reaction to Amy Pascal and her talking
about the venom movie being MCU adjacent.
Well those movies will all take place in
the world that we are now creating for
you know Peter Parker
I mean they'll be adjuncts to it
they may be different locations but it
will still all be in the same world and
they will be connected to each other as well.
This is a good way to think about
the venom the Morbius in any possible
big sinister six movies the special
weaponry that Tyrese has on his wrists
gauntlet is actually supposed to be made
by Oscorp so apparently there will be
some Oscorp stuff happening in the
Morbius movie but there's been no
mention of them casting an actor for
Norman Osborn and I don't think that
they have I think that they're just
starting to reference Oscorp within this
larger universe the venom to crossover
moments are also supposed to be
connected to all the Tom Hollands
spider-man crossover moments they're
sort of getting it all out in one big
burst and it's all about what's going on
with Michael Keaton's vulture character
when Morbius walks by him in his white
prison uniform and vulture jokes that
he's done being a good guy
too it's actually supposed to be happening
at the same prison where Cletus Kasady
carnage is being held the lead that
they're supposed to be making in the
Morbius movie is that vulture and
scorpion at some point between
spider-man homecoming is spider-man far
from home after all the snaps and the
blip back have been transferred to the
same prison where carnage is being kept
at and apparently the reason why you see
Morbius walking past vulture chatting
him up like it's no big deal on the
street is because there's a big prison
break in the sinister six
carnage villains all bust out so that
kind of explains why carnage is walking
around in a red and yellow Hawaiian
shirt during all the venom 2 footage we
saw them filming earlier this year and
obviously during the venom 2 trailer
they'll have some easter egg scenes for
spider-man and Morbius stuff just like
the Morbius trailer so that this whole
timeline makes sense because it sounds
like venom 2 is going to take place
after the events of Morbius but even
though there's all this spider-man stuff
happening in Morbius and venom 2 there's
been no mention of Morbius venom or
carnage showing up anywhere in
spider-man 3 but I think it's okay to
assume that there'll be some
continuation to them developing this
sinister six Michael Keaton vulture plot
this starts in Morbius it's not too much
of a stretch to assume they'll be some
kind of post credits scene that
references eventual crossover with those
characters as for the Matt Smith
character I know you're all wondering
what he's doing in the Morbius movie
he's actually playing the main villain
he's hunger from the comics who's
another vampire-like creature that feeds
on humans the movie version of the
character is a little bit different from
the comics but he's still manipulating
Morbius into becoming Morbius seeking
out his special treatment with these
bats that you see in the trailer then
him becoming the living vampire so it's
him trying to manipulate Morbius through
the movie I haven't heard anything about
them bringing Matt Smith back and future
Morbius sequels so feel free to theory
craft about how the movie deals or does
not deal with him by the end if the
first Morbius movie does well though of
course they're going to  try and do a sequel
I'm hoping that they eventually try to
cross them over with Marvel's new blade
in some of the darker characters like
Moon Knight eventually but as you saw in
the clip that I put at the beginning of
this video one of Sony's official
accounts posted this trailer video
saying that it's going to be released
August 7th which is one week after the
original release date so it seems like
Sony's just bumping Morbius by a little
which i think is great in venom two
thankfully has not been delayed yet but
it's not coming out to the beginning
of October so I think a lot of people
are just expecting everything to get
better around August so August might be
when Marvel tries to release the Black
Widow movie they haven't announced a new
release date yet and they did say that
the Black Widow delay will not affect
the rest of the Marvel phase four
timeline so that includes the Falcon and
Winter Soldier episodes which are also
supposed to come in August the one
division episodes in all the other stuff
like marvels of turtles which is coming
out of November some of you also
messaged me asking about potential venom
to trailer leaked scenes so I'll do a
video on that tomorrow after I find out
a little bit more about what's going on
but it also might be an indicator that
they're going to release the vet and to
trailer very soon because if you
remember a little while ago Sony did the
exact same thing with the first Morbius
trailer allowing some Morbius images to
leak out just a couple days before they
released the official trailer Marvel was
also planning on releasing the first
Eternals trailer with the Black Widow
release but because that's been delayed
the PI just push it by another month or
so so a turtle's trailer sometime this
summer hopefully that explains a little
bit about what's going on with Tom
Hollands spider-man crossing over into
the venom and the Morbius movies issues
of the Sony movies will sort of dance
around some of the other Avengers
related stuff it only talk about what
spider-man has been doing for the last
couple of years there'll be a bunch more
Marvel videos coming up so everyone
leave your requests and your big
questions in the comments below
everyone click here for my new
spider-man 3 video and everyone click
here for my new black panther 2
Easter  Egg video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!